well i'm curious i mean when this came
your way did you know who clifford was
did you just know him as sort of a dog
did you know anything about his stories
well i mean he was very much i mean he
was created in 1963 i was born in 1970
i mean he i feel like clifford was
always kind of a staple in my house
honestly and then when my daughter was
little she the books were around so it
was kind of this clifford was just
always been this kind of loving presence
in the home
and so to kind of be a part and to
really see kind of the creation of
clifford to see how clifford grew up
that was really special to be a part of
i mean even though i play kind of a bad
guy but
this guy is less of a mustache twirling
bad guy and more of like a businessman
bad guy
it's funny because i think just because
of the news lately i kept thinking of
him as mark zuckerberg
how
how much of who this guy was
how much was on the page how much did
you have freedom to find him was there
anyone that you modeled him after
i don't know if i modeled him after i
mean i know clothing-wise he was kind of
a tech guy so they wanted like a steve
jobs like black turtleneck and
jeans and stuff but
he
i love i think when playing kind of evil
characters i always want to be careful
not to just kind of play an idea of
somebody but to really kind of find that
part in him and he you know he had this
tech company he put a lot of money into
it he manipulates nature for profit
his employees are making like two-headed
goats he's really ticked off at him
because they're not doing their jobs he
sees this dog and he's like there's my
saving grace
and he starts you know grabbing for
straws but i think why i love playing
these kind of characters is because they
never win
it never works out for him you know
because people should not live like that
and so playing that kind of watching
that unravel and that kind of
destruction of that that's what's really
fun because he falls apart this guy
completely falls apart
what was it like to play someone who has
a two-headed animal who has an angry
lamb i mean there's all these crazy
things happening like how do you justify
that as
falling in line with the character
well when you're working with someone
like you know alec alex moffitt from snl
he was kind of my assistant and jessica
nguyen and
we were just kind of having fun and
at the time we couldn't really see these
characters because you just because of
spiritual effects and so you kind of had
to react like this sheep coming at you
and stuff
and so
that was you know really fun just to
kind of think how that was working but i
just i was amazed at the end to be able
to see the final product and to see
these goats and even clifford and
let me tell you right now
these these special effects people they
need
all the awards you guys i mean they like
works painstakingly hard with details
and stuff it's really there's that last
scene of clifford going through the
traffic
that is just like i don't even know i
don't even understand it it's baffling
to me it's really amazing
yeah i was really impressed with how
seamless it really looked in this
because a lot of times you can tell
something has yeah
i just thought it this is like the the
best i've seen it look
yeah and it's i mean
that the work they put into that but
also just this message of clifford that
i
i think i get i mean even though i'm
playing the background what i get
excited about is
you know one of my favorite scenes in it
is there's a scene where um emily is
holding clifford and she loves clifford
and that's what makes him grow
and after these years that we've had
where it's like social media and
everybody's being critical and
everybody's being judgmental that's not
gonna bring growth that's just not gonna
bring it but it's like
celebrating the differences you know
loving each other supporting and having
empathy that's where growth is going to
happen and this is like yeah this is a
children's movie but it's it's a message
that adults really need to tune in on
you know
so then at any point did you hesitate
about being the bad guy who wants to
harm the cute animal
um not at all
no um i'll show you my little cute
animals you want to see that's that's
walter right there yeah that's francis
these are little gifts that my wife and
i gave us but like i i it's fun to play
the foe like i love playing the but he's
not evil he's just misunderstood
christina he's just misunderstood he's
got he's had a lot of trauma
and he's working it out he's trying to
hurt the cute animals so that that is
pretty evil
it's pretty evil it's pretty evil but it
comes from pain comes from a lot of pain
well also congrats on season two of
mysterious benedict society thank you
had such tremendous fun watching that
show
what are you most looking forward to
with getting to continue that and go
back to
that show
yeah i uh i love that you mentioned it
because i really love you talk about
empathy i really love
what that story was saying but also just
the the visuals of it what we were what
the what they were able to create and
the beauty and
the the aesthetic design of it um just
the whole package i really loved and it
says and the second book is is going to
the kids have gotten a lot older it's
going to be a little different um but
there's going to be a lot of similar
themes and i don't know i just what
trenton stewart created in those books
is really special so i'm so thankful
disney has allowed us to continue it
honestly
you've been working with some really
tremendous young gifted actors lately
what has that been like for you with the
kids on the show with the kids in this
movie yeah
is that inspiring as an actor
it really is i was not
it's not as mature as these kids are
but like
i you know these even that you know the
kids on benedict society you know they
came into the show during a pandemic
they left their families well they had
the one parent with them but they
couldn't go back home to see their
friends they're signing up for this big
show everybody's wearing masks like it's
pretty daunting and they just jumped in
you have someone like darby who was
young when she was doing this movie
she's working across which she can't see
puppets and holding
really these kids really stepping up to
the plate and i just i really admire it
a lot and darby just comes off very
authentic in this movie she's a really
good actress
and she was so young you know i just
think i wasn't there i think i was just
wondering when i was gonna get my next
mcflurry at mcdonald's at that age
that's all i cared about
what do you think happened to this guy
after we leave him in this movie like
where do you think he went
after this
i think he's probably just he's got
clifford on a on a
on a dart board and just like at prison
and just throwing darts at it
um
hopefully he's got a tremendous amount
of therapy in dealing with the trauma
that he's been working out
maybe he's at it maybe you know what
maybe he did a 180 and is at a dog
shelter and he's like you know what i'm
a broken man and i need to start
i need to start showing some love to
these animals
or
in like in light of life unfortunately
maybe he's like
really successful and it's like he's
found a way around the system which is
really sad but hopefully that hasn't
happened
well maybe maybe some dog cuddles
changed him and turned him around i know
he needed to do one of those youtube
videos where people just hand you
puppies yeah that's that's what he needs
yeah he needs a he's got a whole youtube
show where people just hand them puppies
well thank you for talking to me about
this it's such a fun movie i i really
thanks christina i appreciate you taking
the time on a saturday
well thank you it's a good distraction i
mean how can you say no to a giant red
dog
[Laughter]
all right well i'll see you next time
you